so just arrived at the Crowne Plaza I've
been nominated for an award like this
I'm definitely gonna get one but it's
gonna be a great evening all the same
have actually brought my dad along with
me so I'm going to go enjoy some good
food and some entertainment and fingers
crossed I might even win an award let's
find out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they call me son who just getting a
drink and it's like we just heard his
name my neighbors
[Music]
what time this if I ever remember the
legend II never retire you know
if I ask you where do you want to get to
in your life most people would think
within their industry within their
speciality they want to be like kingpin
on top and I'm used to people saying I
want to be the best speaker I want to be
the best trained I want to be the best
this that the other this this guy turns
man that says okay so if you can imagine
Hulk Hogan and the Ultimate Warrior they
they they're like speakers of the WWF
WWE right he said I want to be Vince
McMahon I want to be the guy that all of
the top trainers are training for that's
a heavyweight mindset just think about
that mindset for a second because most
people don't think like that
Hey Harrington here and then we
obviously the one only the amazing
Samuel Leeds we here at the professional
speakers Academy Awards dinner and guess
what this chap just won three Academy
Awards skies incredible he's changing
lives to make a difference his huge Tube
channel is incredible his events are
massive look if you're not currently in
into Vince's guy is the real deal
absolutely fantastic no really really
pleased that I won free award to be
event I didn't know for sure if I was
gonna win one winning three was
fantastic so I'm a multi Multi multi
multi multi award-winning speaker great
to be part of a network of other
like-minded speakers see some old
friends and tired because I've just
finished a crash course so I've come
straight to this event but really really
humbled thank you so much guys if you've
been to any of our training programs if
you're here tonight if you follow me on
YouTube just massive thank you I'm
really humbled and look forward to
hopefully coming back next year and
seeing some other people win some awards
as well okay so we're just come out of
the professional speakers academy award
ceremony it is a room absolutely packed
with some of the best talent I'm
speaking educating motivating and so on
some of these people earning millions a
month and this guy here right here
one more
than anybody else in there he won three
awards one of which was for the best
male speaker one was for the best
YouTube account and what's the third one
business growth best business growth so
this guy in a room of some of the most
talented people still is head and
shoulders above just everybody in there
absolutely chimes if you want to learn
and you want to be successful the best
thing you can do is find somebody who's
very successful in what you want to be
successful in and you can teach it this
is the guy happens to be my son
[Music]